adding to the very very very bad 10-day
period of news
for republicans and magga
and former trump officials rudy giuliani
has now been notified he is indeed under
criminal investigation in that georgia
scam that they tried to pull new york
times reporting giuliani is told he is a
target of trump election investigation
in georgia
yeah
lawyers for giuliani have been told that
he's a target of a criminal
investigation in georgia into election
interference by donald trump and his
advisors one of giuliani's lawyers said
monday
giuliani spearheaded efforts to keep
trump in power as his personal lawyer
and emerged in recent weeks as a central
figure in the inquiry conducted by
fannie willis the d.a of fulton county
georgia which encompasses most of
atlanta
earlier this summer prosecutors
questioned witnesses before a special
grand jury about rudy's appearances
before state legislative panels in 2020
remember that was when rudy was flying
around doing these hearings nobody was
under oath and rudy was farting at the
hearings and transmitting covid that's
what they're referring to
um he spent hours peddling false
conspiracy theories about secret
suitcases of democratic ballots and
corrupted voting machines
this is the latest in a widening swath
of trouble writes the times though he
got some good news which is that he's
unlikely to face charges in the federal
criminal inquiry into his ties with
ukraine
so we kind of have covered the rudy
story rudy could have spent the rest of
his days being
mayor 911
and just kind of farting around for lack
of a better term but he chose this path
he chose to
hook his wagon to the horse that is
trump
and now that path has consequences and
it's rudy's own doing will trump say i
barely knew the guy rudy really had no
role in anything is that what's coming
it doesn't seem particularly likely but
what we're learning is that being a
lawyer for trump is a criminally risky
thing to do look at what happened to
michael cohen
look at what happened to sydney powell
uh who has now been disbarred in a
number of different places rudy's under
criminal probe eric hirschman believe
eric hirschman was white house counsel
he now has been subpoenaed and you know
years ago we started joking about how
maga really means making attorneys get
attorneys
it really seems to and uh couldn't have
happened to a nicer guy is what some are
saying about rudy giuliani maybe that's
the case maybe he's a nice guy but these
people do deserve it these are not
victims these are perpetrators and i
know that because of the advanced age of
some of these folks there is a reaction
among some to say this is sad these are
victims at the end of the day just leave
them alone
these are perpetrators and the victims
are the united states and its people
those are the victims and we'll see
where this goes
all of these clips you can find on the
david pakman show instagram search
instagram
for david pakman show find us there
i know that many of you who watch this
show also love documentaries if you
don't have curiosity stream you are
missing out our sponsor curiosity stream
is the only streaming platform
specializing in documentaries that's all
they have documentaries and this lets
them deliver the newest and most
critically acclaimed documentaries stuff
you're not going to find on other
streaming services curiosity stream also
has a whole bunch of super high quality
original content you won't find anywhere
else the other night i watched asteroids
comets and meteors as many of you know
i'm super interested in what seems to be
the inevitable direction we are going
which is the eventual mining of
asteroids and to be perfectly frank i
never remember the difference between
asteroids comets and meteors and that's
one of the things that i learned check
out curiosity streams catalog you'll see
they have a much better selection of
documentaries and the other platforms
they also have an app for your tv phone
tablet and computer and the best part is
my audience gets curiosity stream for
under two bucks a month
when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below